[Music]
you look out at a body of water whether
it's a pond river ocean even your own
bathtub you are peering into the home of
countless microorganisms some are simple
others more complex and perhaps among
the most stunning are diatoms though
they are probably not in your bathtub
these are photosynthetic single-celled
eukaryotes whose silica shells render
them almost like jewels they're sparkly
and distinctive appearance have
captivated microbiologists since the
earliest days of the field in the 18th
century but we suspect that most of you
haven't heard of bass ilaria one of the
earliest diatoms described in the
scientific literature they're like one
of those deeply specific niches you find
when you're exploring a new hobby one of
those narrow obsessions that you had no
clue existed until you happened upon a
forum about 1990 Swedish hip-hop that
goes back 300 pages we have not stumbled
on any 300 page bass ilaria forms though
we are open to suggestions if you know
of a good one but it does seem like
people who are interested in bass ilaria
are really interested in basilar EF
including one notable drunken attempt to
mimic their behavior as humans we'll get
to that more in a bit the source of the
fascination lies in the mystery and
contradictions of the microbes movement
which has so mesmerized us that it may
have obscured some other truths about
the organism
[Music]
let's observe this dance from the cheap
seats fully zoomed out so we can watch
them perform across this microscopic
stage the basilar iya pixel affair
begins compact but it quickly extends in
both directions and extends and extends
some more until it is stretched across a
good portion of the screen
[Music]
then it contracts back inward back into
that more discreet state only to renew
that dance again this time reaching only
in one direction it's a remarkable feat
of microscopic acrobatics taking the
organism across the stage even as it
stays in one spot
in fact this Bassel aureus movement is
so coordinated it almost seems like a
worm a weird one like a pokey
abstraction of the nematode squirming
around next to it the first person to
describe basilar yep axilla fur and it's
dance was otto friedrich muller in 1783
he described the organism as a peg
animal the pegs as he saw them were
inflexible cylinders that contained some
sort of yellow creature or film when the
organism was at rest the pegs formed a
quadrilateral and when it moved the
outer pegs began to slide followed by
their neighbour until a whole sequence
of pegs slid out into a line remember
this was the earliest days of our
understanding of the micro cosmos when
we still thought of life as being
divided only between plants and animals
and based on his observations Muller
struggled with an important question
were the basilar eeeh he was looking at
a single animal or was it some kind of
animal group that came together and
coordinated this incredible formation he
debated himself back and forth
ultimately deciding that this must be
just one single animal after all he
could think of no parallel example of
such synchronized movement among animals
in the macro world it seemed improbable
that nature would conceive of such a
thing in any level and honestly it still
does
while mueller acknowledged that the
micro cosmos was full
strange things in the framework of how
we understood nature at that time it
seemed to him that this must be one
animal an animal he named Vibrio taxa
liver despite the value of his
observations and his reasoning mueller
was of course wrong the strange animal
he had seen was actually not one animal
it was not even an animal at all those
pegs were each microscopic individuals
that had assembled into that larger
entity and through various
reclassifications over the years Vibrio
packs a liver eventually became known as
bass ilaria packs a liver a cosmopolitan
diatom found in both marine and
freshwater environments each bass ilaria
colony is actually the product of a
series of divisions meaning that this
whole ensemble is made up of clones the
individual cells have a slit called the
reef through which they excrete a kind
of adhesive substance that keeps them
attached to their neighbouring sister
cell the movements of the colony are
likely driven by light at night they're
usually in their compact state remaining
still and during the day they stay
extended the cycle of expansion and
contraction over and over that's mostly
observed at dawn and dusk vac Solaria
packs a liver is also known as bass
ilaria paradox ah which is a fitting
name because despite all the mechanisms
we have been able to decipher there are
many questions left to understand
there's no obvious method of
communication between cells or obvious
moving parts within each one so how do
they synchronize their movement how do
they understand where their neighbors
are these are the same questions you
might ask while you're watching a
talented ensemble of dancers wear each
individual's movements are perfectly
aligned through intricate choreography
but that display is a feat of training
and precision guided by music and
internalized by each performer these are
microbes what directs them that question
has been the basis of many Edyta mists
fascination with bass ilaria for
centuries a fascination that has
preoccupied minds and inspired creative
feats in his description of the Mueller
took 10 pages to argue with himself over
whether this kind of coordinated
movement between discrete organisms was
even possible and we were able to read
his words in English because they were
translated from the original Danish back
in 2005 the translator noted that this
activity they were engaged in was
supposed to be a fun relaxing side
project a side project that involved
having to read Gothic lettering process
18th century scholarly Danish diction
and contend with the physical challenges
of decaying old books all that work just
to understand the first words used to
describe this species the foundational
text as it were for an ongoing tradition
of Bassel area observation and obsession
there are whole fandoms lovely as they
are built on much less effort there's
also the story of the 1987 North
American diatom symposium where around
30 people attempted their own
transformational work the basilar iya
shuffle alcohol was involved as was a
chant that went do the bass ilaria do
the bass ilaria in the words of someone
who was there the dance was marked by a
quote general lack of physical
coordination of the individual persons
you could take that as a condemnation of
the people involved or as an homage to
the much simpler and yet much more
synchronized or
who inspired them but in focusing so
much on this movement it's taken time to
uncover other secrets of the basilar
eeeh since the days of Muller scientists
have thought that there was just one
species distributed in all sorts of
waters all around the world after all
how many species could there be
exhibiting such a complicated way of
life but in 2007 more than 200 years
after basilar area had first been
described a scientist studied the
internal structures of the organism and
realized that there were actually
several distinct species distributed in
different waters Muller the original
bass ilaria admirer wrote of what he saw
quote it is in the microscopical world
that such unusual sites most often meet
the strange dance he observed would go
on to underpin his incorrect
classification of the organism and over
time diatom enthusiasts would continue
to be so fixated on this collective
behavior that it would take time to
notice the individuality of its varied
species you could almost write a fable
around our observations of the organism
with a simple moral to not be so
distracted by beauty but that feels a
little hypocritical on our part given
that we savor the diversion of the micro
cosmos is allure the artistry of nature
whether large or small has always been
an inspiration for scientific inquiry
and as researchers come to better
understand Vasil area there will only be
new sources of charm and beauty to
discover
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you of
course to all of the people who make
this show possible if you like it these
are the people to thank our patrons on
patreon thank you so much to all you if
you want to check it out and help us
make more good content maybe get some
better equipment you can find us at
patreon.com slash journey to micro if
you want to see more from our master of
microscopes James Weiss you can check
out Jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
you